- [Gary] There's only a
couple ways to run a business.
You either sell ahead of it,
that allows you to stay alive,
you raise money or
you have a side job and
you fucking do it on the side.
There's nothing else.
- And then how to
get those people to,
how do you hire people when
you haven't got
resources to do that?
- [Gary] You don't.
You do it yourself or you find a
cofounder if you
can't code the app.
- I'm starting to program myself
but I know that's not the good
way to go down to
do everything yourself.
- [Gary] Then I would
go to Meetup.com or
read London tech blog.
You say you are you in Saudi
Arabia and you came here or
you are here now.
- I moved here to do this.
- [Gary] Got it.
Go to Meetup.com or
other London tech apps,
find developers, there's a
fucking developer right here
somewhere and
see if you like them.
- [Man 2] I got a
spreadsheet of developers.
I'll send it to you.
- Oh, alright.
- [Gary] Seriously.
Dude, honestly life is
about fucking taking it.
Here you are, you
fucked waited three,
four hours, you
ask this question.
Dude right here
is good fucking dude.
- I've waited
three years in desert.
- [Gary] Waited three
fucking years in desert.
- No, I've been on
construction sites.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It wasn't my problem.
There's a custom over there
and he didn't want to come down.
He couldn't come.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Everybody else in the company,
they want to go down there.
I drove 600 miles to
go there, close the deal,
got the check and came back.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Knowing that I wasn't
going to get a bonus for it.
- [Gary] Yeah. 'Course.
- But I still wanted to
put my name in the company.
- [Gary] I get it.
- Until now, those same
people are calling me now--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- saying Yousef,
we want you to bring,
I'm telling you sorry,
I'm not in the company.
- Take that man's
fucking list, right now,
get his fucking info.
- I'll work, I'll grind.
So it's just I don't
know the direction.
- [Gary] I get it,
man and by the way,
there's a million people that
are willing to outwork anybody
and don't have the talent of
strategy and you don't win.
Like, that's fucking real.
There's this notion that like
the problem is that people don't
realize it takes multiple.
It's not just hustle.
It's not talent.
It's not just serendipity.
It's not just timing.
It's not just leadership.
It's not just
emotional intelligence.
It's fucking all of it. Right?
Or you might be a number two and
you need somebody who's got that
and you're the fucking grinder
and the engine behind the body
of the nice
sports car, you know?
But you're the engine.
Do you the understand?
- [Man] Yeah, sure.
- It's about that.
- [Man 3] There's
nothing wrong with that either.
- Are you fucking crazy?
I literally have 20 Facebook top
hundred employee best friends
who fucking have
$100 million in
cash in their bank.
Like I love everybody who thinks
they need to be an entrepreneur
to make that kind of money.
The 400th employee at Facebook
is gonna make more money than
99% of people standing
out here that want it so bad.
Yes, there's
nothing wrong with that.
If that's what you want.
Now if you want the high
of being the guy or girl,
well then go do that.
But you just might make $80,000
a year but you got your high.
Or you just might want to parent
and you want to
mold your kid it like...
People just, I want
people to think for themselves.
You know?
I want people to
think for themselves.
When I hear somebody's that's
that hungry and willing to grind
and, right, so then you gotta
figure pretty soon that if you
have the chops to come up with
the ideas or do the things and
execute them and if you don't,
you better strap on
to somebody who can.
Got it?
- [Man] Alright.
- Because there's a lot of
people in my organization that
are talented as fuck,
smart as fuck,
but they're not
enough to see the...
My brother who's a fucking beast
would stand here right now and
be like I told Gary nobody would
ever pay more than $5,000 a
month for social media.
AJ's the smartest fucking
dude I know but I was right.
And he wasn't
because I see shit.
Like him, maybe you don't.
That's okay.
There's a lot of
things I wish I did.
I wish I was better and stronger
my financial kind of like
understanding 'cause if I was
smart enough to know that
I could've taken people's money
and took 20% of the action and
invested in
Facebook and Twitter in 2007,
I'd be a billionaire already.
I was right, just wasn't smart
enough 'cause I didn't go to
fucking a single course in
finance and economics that made
me understand that there's a
way to carry people's money.
I already knew
tons of millionaires.
I coulda went around,
raised $100 million,
deployed it against Facebook and
Twitter $20 million of my money
against the
multiple that I made,
I'd have fucking
$1.7 billion, piece a cake.
All I didn't know was
that you could do that.
And that's simple shit that
everybody knows or not everybody
but a lot of people.
So we've all got
strength and weaknesses.
Alright, I need to
get the fuck out of here.
Who haven't I said hello to?